[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate che stasera dopo questo
speech andate a casa e domani avete un
colloquio di selezione a cui tenete
moltissimo e che che non volete per
niente
sbagliare andate a dormire e Cominciate
a vi viene un pensiero automatico e se
andasse male E se non fossi all'altezza
di quello che il selezionatore si
aspetta E se sbagliassi e se mi
impappinato ad avere un aumento
dell'ansia
e continuate a
pensarci dopo un po' che state lì non
dormendo vi viene un altro
pensiero adesso non sto dormendo e
questo sicuramente non favorisce il
fatto che io possa avere un buon
Colloquio domani di selezione Ecco
questo pensiero ripetitivo questo
pensiero altrove dalla vostra realtà
concreta che però Voi vivete come vostro
di cui vi darò delle linee di
spiegazione È il rimuginio o la
ruminazione Come sono le caratteristiche
del rumino le caratteristiche sono
queste è verbale è astratto è negativo
ed è
perseverante non si ferma mai oppure è
difficile
fermarlo
e all'inizio negli anni 80 il rimuginio
il concetto di rimuginio è stato
studiato da un dottor da da un
dottorando della Penn State University
che si chiamava Tom borkovec e che stava
cercando di capire l'insonnia e si rese
conto che circa l' 80% delle persone che
non dormono non dorme perché è preso
dentro pensieri negativi e ansiosi
Ma come funziona funziona così che ho
questo pensiero
automatico che poi diventa un rimuginio
che poi mi dà l'ansia ma ansia mi
rafforza il rimuginio ed è un circolo
vizioso che è difficile interrompere
all'inizio è stato studiato
nell'ansia domani come farò l'esempio
che vi ho fatto come farò al colloquio
di selezione
e però
dopo ad esempio no noi l'abbiamo
studiato in Italia sui disturbi
dell'alimentazione non c'erano dati che
confermassero che le ragazze con
disturbi
dell'alimentazione rugin avano in realtà
la loro mente è piena di rimuginio ma
non tanto è solo sugli aspetti devo
dimagrire ma anche in generale sul mondo
una visione catastrofica e impaurita del
mondo poi rimuginio è stato studiato
anche su un'altra emozione e adesso vi
faccio vedere un esempio ho perso
qualcosa ho avuto un intoppo ho avuto un
fallimento una perdita un abbandono e
cominciata a pensare a questa cosa
dopo un po' che siete lì che pensate a a
questo evento doloroso che è perduto e
che non potete
recuperare viene un'emozione di
tristezza e poi anche un'idea ma sono io
sono io che non son degna di amore che
sono indegna che sono fallita che è
giusto che venga trattata così e come
vedete anche qui abbiamo un circolo
vizioso che è difficile fermare e in cui
la sofferenza si mantiene il
l'esito da un punto di vista del
comportamento può essere il
ritiro chiudersi in
casa ridurre l'esplorazione fuori dalla
propria casa o anche bere per
dimenticare Ecco questo lo fanno anche i
rimuginato Ori ansiosi
Ecco più recentemente una ventina d'anni
fa
il il pensiero ripetitivo è stato
studiato sulla rabbia non dovevi farmi
questo io ti aspettavo non sei venuto
Non mi hai telefonato come ti permetti
di trattarmi così io non io non voglio
essere trattata così te la farò pagare
Ecco ti punirò Te la farò pagare questo
è la
ruminazione rabbiosa la ruminazione
rabbiosa nel tempo fa aumentare la
rabbia non la sopisce ed è difficile da
fermare se non sappiamo gestire questa
emozione Ecco
e può dare dei comportamenti di
aggressione
verbale di aggressione di attacco Ecco
e spesso anche bevo così non mi
dimentico di quanto sono arrabbiato non
riesco a togliermi dalla testa questo
questo
pensiero ma un inizio di rimuginio qui
dentro ce l'abbiamo tutti Cominciamo a
pensare una cosa che ci preoccupa un un
sacco o che ci fa sentire un po'
inadeguati La differenza è che questo
l'abbiamo dimostrato noi in un articolo
per psychological medicine alcuni anni
fa la differenza è che il fenomeno è
uguale ma le persone con sofferenza
mentale non riescono a lasciarlo da
parte sono completamente identificati
non riescono a smettere
Ecco Quali sono gli esiti di di questo
di questo coso gli esiti sono di molto
sono molto diversi possono essere esiti
corporali la stanchezza l'insonnia come
vi vi ho già detto la La debolezza
dolori viscerali fino ad avere danni
alla alle coronarie i rimuginato ansiosi
cronici rischiano di avere danni alle
coronarie perché è come se mantenessero
viva l'emozione ansiosa nel tempo e e e
quindi lo stress che la che che l'ansia
dà se non scende come dovrebbe scendere
come scende normalmente poi ci sono
anche degli esiti emotivi ho un'emozione
di paura o di rabbia o di tristezza ma
non riesco a lasciarla andare e continua
a starci dentro a starci dentro il mio
pensiero porta la porta avanti e quindi
non riesco a far fare neanche alle
emozioni questo passaggio verso la
discesa
e sono attaccata a questi aspetti
emotivi dolenti poi ci sono degli Esi
mentali cognitivi non riesco a decidere
sono inibito all'azione rimando le
decisioni
procrastino e poi la mia attenzione
viene ristretta dentro questi pensieri
negativi al punto tale che non riesco a
essere creativa per affrontare i
problemi del mondo e quindi siamo meno
recettivi e flessibili da tutto ciò che
quotidianamente gli input del mondo
danno a noi che ci chiniamo in mezzo e
ci consuma risorse mentali diventiamo
Veramente meno capaci di risolvere
problemi e la nostra attenzione è fissa
lì e questo lì è un altrove che non è la
realtà anche se noi siamo identificati
con questo tipo di pensiero e la
consideriamo la nostra realtà Insomma ci
porta altrove lontano dal mondo pratici
meno capaci di adattarci e meno capaci
di essere flessibili nel camminare nel
mondo immaginate di cadere in una buca e
cominciare a scavare per cercare di
uscire dalla buca e questo vi impedisce
di vedere che basterebbe Alzare gli
occhi e forse riuscireste a trovare un
modo
in per uscire ma se non ci aiuta perché
lo facciamo Ecco questo è interessante
perché in qualche modo a volte i
rimuginato sonoo figli di rimuginato
oppure una famiglia cui si ugina molto
Oppure ho avuto situazioni caotiche
complesse Oppure ho una vulnerabilità
alla paura Insomma si impara si impara a
passare molto tempo con questi pensieri
astratti che non ci portano da nessuna
parte perché ci sembra di trovare
soluzioni di non sbagliare di
approfondire di essere più
profondi di non essere sopraffatti dalle
cose del mondo che ci sembrano complesse
Inoltre ci può dare un sollievo
momentaneo sono davanti a un problema
vado lì e mi allontano dal dall'input e
vado in un posto in cui mi illudo che
sto cercando di trovare il problema la
soluzione per ritornare del problema mi
illudo di controllare la realtà di non
sbagliare l' un'illusione momentanea che
in quel momento magari in adolescenza mi
alleviava la
tensione ma non è così pensare meno è
pensare meglio e questo è molto
importante come concetto
Perché pensare meno ma stare con le mani
nel fango del nostro mondo è una
modalità di vita più adattiva ma lo
posso curare questo rimuginio ci sono
delle cure Sì pur essendo un fenomeno
che è stato adesso ormai c'è una
cinquantina d'anni però è arrivata nella
ribalta clinica da una ventina in Italia
anche da meno ci sono delle tecniche
specie terapia cognitivo comportamentale
per poterlo curare la prima cosa da fare
è che voi dovete essere consapevoli che
rimuginato perché a volte dei pazienti
vengono da noi e non e non si siedono
dicendo sono un grande rimuginato ma ci
portano i contenuti di questo rimuginio
come se fosse un modo sensato di
interpretare il mondo Io invece devo
imparare a riconoscere la mia mente
quando va lì e chiedermi mi sta aiutando
in questo momento la mia mente mi mi è
utile mi aiuta a risolvere i problemi
Ecco questo è il prim cioè identificare
il questo questa dimensione del pensiero
mentre la stiamo vivendo il secondo
punto è che dobbiamo renderci conto che
non è incontrollabile e che ha dei costi
ha dei costi perché come vi ho già
spiegato prima ci rallenta il nostro
stare nel mondo risolvendo problemi
flessibile ed è controllabile e qui ci
sono anche degli studi molto belli
sull'attenzione perché Anticamente si
pensava che l'attenzione fosse
automatica Io entro qui e
automaticamente Mi rivolgo a voi mentre
in realtà l'attenzione è qualcosa che
dipende molto dalla mia decisione di
dirigerla e quindi io posso decidere di
prendere il rimuginio che è dentro di me
e di non farmi attrarre da questa la mia
attenzione da questo fenomeno poi
po come faccio È come se io avessi qui
un canto delle sirene e che questo canto
delle sirene mi chiamasse e mi chiama mi
chiama questo canto la mia attenzione
vuole andare lì Vuole andare lì io devo
sapere però che come tutti i disturbi
anche del mio pensiero se io o di questo
telefono se io non rispondo si estingue
EC Ecco e questo
è così immaginate anche un'altra
metafora voi state guardando una partita
a tennis che palleggiano e poi a un
certo punto con un vostro amico dice
vabbè ciao e vi andate a prendere un
caffè e loro continuano a palleggiare Ma
voi l'avete lasciati lì non state lì a
farvi catturare dal gioco delle palline
che che si buttano da un lato
all'altro quindi volgere l'attenzione
alla realtà pr
è un un punto importante della cura del
rimuginio e poi un altro punto
importante ed è un compito facile che vi
farà anche sorridere e che noi diamo ai
nostri pazienti è l'indicazione ai
grandi rimuginato quindi grandi ansiosi
ad esempio è l'indicazione Ok adesso
avete lavorato su rimuginio vi hanno
portato dei problemi voi date
l'indicazione guardate in questa
settimana io le do il permesso compito
homework di rimuginare solo Dalle 7:00
alle 7:30 e durante la giornata non
dovete rimuginare Voi capite che in
questo compito c'è già la soluzione per
due motivi Il primo motivo è che
eh alle dalle 7:00 alle 7:30 voi se vi
rendete conto che se lo potete
rimandare non è controllabile non ne
siete schiavi e la seconda cosa che
probabilmente il trigger che vi faceva
rimuginare alle tre del pomeriggio alle
7:00 non c'è più e quindi voi avete
passato una giornata in fondo senza
rimuginare Infatti i pazienti tornano E
dicono no Io dalle 7:00 alle 7:30 c'ho
rius c'ho provato a rimuginare ma non ci
sono proprio riuscito ecco insomma per
concludere Avete mai pensato che voi
siete qui in questa bella sala e che
tornate a casa e dovete
prepararvi perché avete un colloquio il
giorno dopo
e tornate a casa Incominciate a fare
questo pensiero che vi cattia Dio il
colloquio lo lasciate là vi voltate lo
lasciate lì
e abbracciate vostra moglie
chiacchierate coi vostri figli vi vedete
un film su Netflix Insomma Forse vi
preparate al colloquio del giorno dopo
senza essere catturati in modo inutile e
rigido da un pensiero astratto che
sicuramente non è pieno di contenuti
utili non vi può aiutare Insomma adesso
dirò una cosa un po' provocatoria Se non
siete Manuel Kant e non state scrivendo
la critica e la ragion pura per noi
umani che viviamo nel mondo adattandoci
al mondo risolvendo problemi il pensiero
è
sopravvalutato pensate di meno Fate meno
bilanci di chi siete veramente fate di
più Fatevi attirare dagli stimoli del
nostro mondo che è pieno di cose
interessanti da guardare e questa è una
regola molto importante sia in ambito
patologico perché Riduce la sofferenza
Mentale Ma è anche una regola per una
vita più serena e con questo vi
[Applauso]
ringrazio